ما مدى ارتفاع خطر الغزو الروسي في
الوقت الحالي
،
إنه أمر جيد جدًا
لأنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك ، ولم يحركوا أيًا من قواتهم
إلى الخارج ، لقد نقلوا المزيد من القوات في
المرتبة الأولى ، ولديهم سبب
للاعتقاد بأنهم
متورطون  في عملية العلم الكاذب للحصول
على عذر للذهاب في
كل مؤشر لدينا هو أنهم
مستعدون للذهاب إلى هجوم قطار
أوكرانيا رقم واحد رقم اثنين ، لقد كنت
أنتظر ردًا من بوتين على
رسالتي بأن ردي عليه
لقد وصل الأمر إلى تلك السفارة العضلية ، فهم
هنا في الواقع فصائلي ، هل أنت
حقًا هنا لم أقرأه بعد ،
لا يمكنني التعليق ،
نعم ،
إحساسي أن هذا سيحدث في غضون
الأيام العديدة القادمة ، ما الذي يعتقده هذا
هو أنه لا يزال هناك أي مسار دبلوماسي
متاح نعم  هناك فرق واضح
لهذا السبب طلبت من السناتور
سكرتير السناتور بلنكين أن يذهب إلى
الأمم المتحدة ويدلي ببيانه اليوم
أنه سيحدد ما هو هذا الطريق لقد
وضعت طريقا
لبوتين كذلك  حبر الأحد ، لذا هناك طريق
هناك طريق من
خلاله ، هل ستتصل ببوتين أنا لا أتصل
بالطعام ، ليس لدي أي خطط للاتصال بـ بوتين